[Musique]
chaque semaine de nouveaux produits
alimentaires nous sont proposés sont-ils
à prendre ou à laisser au menu
aujourd'hui des pochettes à tortilla
nouveau genre du gruau au smores de la
fondue au fromage et au whisky et des
capuchons de muffins à faire à la maison
pour ceux et ceux qui gaspillent
toujours la partie inférieure de leur
muffins on a une nouveauté ici Isabelle
les capuchons de muffins une nouveauté
qui te plaît vraiment
l'idée était bonne en fait tu es lancé
par Betty cracker le concept est
relativement simple pour nous propose de
conserver la partie du muffin qui est
souvent les gens préfèrent pourquoi
parce qu'elle est croustillante à
l'extérieur très tendre à l'intérieur à
l'oeil c'est clairement un biscuit donc
pour ceux qui ont qui mangent le muffin
pour déjeuner là on passe c'est pas un
bon choix du tout honnêtement acheter ce
produit là c'est payer pour de la farine
et des additifs et il y a une curiosité
il y a pas de bleuets dans la saveur de
du champ ou bleuet non pas du tout c'est
du sucre de l'huile de palme colorant à
Rome bref on a affaire un produit qui
est non seulement très transformé mais
d'un point de vue nutritif 0 c'est une
fausse bonne idée
en termes de l'eau qu'on peut tout de
suite comparer là j'aimerais qu'on me
porte un beau fun merci
donc ici on a un vrai de vrai muffin de
boulangerie c'est un peu plus attirant
que ça et même je suis certaine si je
l'ouvre là en termes de texture vous
voyez à l'intérieur on a vraiment un
aspect sablé de ça à l'intérieur alors
que là on a vraiment une réelle
le sel est très présent la texture est
très banale apprendre ou à laisser pour
moi ça passe pas du tout j'ai
malheureusement et j'essaye d'être
objectif aucun élément positif ni dans
la composition ni dans la valeur
nutritive ni même dans le lot ou
l'expérience gustative
on dit oui au smores sur le bord du feu
en camping l'été avec les amis mais ce
qu'on dit OUI ou gruau au smores matinal
nous arrive avec un gruau instantané
dans lequel ils ont ajouté des morceaux
de biscuits grammes de guimauve et de
chocolat parce que c'est le concept du
smooth donc la fameuse guimauve grillée
le morceau de chocolat entre deux
biscuits grammes je dois dire que j'ai
été agréablement surprise en analysant
ce produit là finalement la composition
générale oui évidemment on a le biscuit
on a le chocolat dedans mais
la guimauve mais la teneur en sucre
totale et raisonnable voire même mieux
que dans plusieurs autres des gruyots
instantanés proposés par quicker
pour toi c'est une belle petite gâterie
pour faire changement attention de ne
pas trop inviter le dessert au déjeuner
parce que c'est pas la meilleure façon
de partir sa journée une autre idée qui
attire notre attention je suis curieuse
de savoir Isabelle d'un point de vue
nutritif est-ce que c'est pochette de
tortillas sont intéressantes
malheureusement en fait on connaît bien
au DEL Paso il nous offre déjà plusieurs
produits dans l'univers de la cuisine
mexicaine depuis un bon moment la
nouveauté qu'on nous propose ici est
simplement une variation sur le thème de
ce qu'on connaît déjà donc une nouvelle
forme de tortilla qui est déjà préfet
c'est ni mieux ni pires que les autres
tortillas similaires de la compagnie
nous propose la grande faiblesse d'un
point de vue nutritionnel de ces
produits là outre la multitude
d'additifs qu'il y a à l'intérieur parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup s'il sodium le kit
c'est proposé pour 4 personnes donc si
je divise par 4 la valeur nutritive de
l'ensemble du kit ça me donne 870 mg de
sodium ce qui prête 40% de nos besoins
quotidiens c'est sûr qu'une partie du
sodium qui vient des assaisonnements et
de la sauce peut-être répond à un besoin
d'une personne qui a une dextérité
réduite donc à prendre ou à laisser je
dirais un bon dépanneur à l'occasion et
vraiment à l'occasion
c'est la saison parfaite pour la fondue
la fondue au fromage avec des amis mais
est-ce que cette préparation est
parfaite pas loin nouveauté qui nous est
proposé par mille et une fondus
entreprise familiale de Québec la base
du concept qu'on nous propose c'est des
fromages 100% locaux dans ce cas-ci ils
ont ajouté un peu de whisky de la
distillerie Saint-Laurent ce que j'aime
particulièrement de ce que fait mille et
une fondue c'est qu'on n'a pas rien
d'ajouter c'est vraiment
très courte liste d'ingrédients le
l'essentiel est là c'est tout simplement
exact donc c'est ce que ce serait si on
faisait la préparation nous-mêmes en
allant à la fromagerie acheter nos
propres fromages mais déjà bien dosé
bien mélanger emballé sous vide donc
longue conservation et se prépare en
quelques minutes
c'est vraiment savoureux oui c'est grave
oui c'est salé mais ce lait autant que
ça devrait l'être pour un véritable
fromage frais et en terme de prix bon
c'est sûr qu'on a à faire un produit
100% fromage et là dans ce cas-ci en
plus avec un alcool fin donc on parle
autour de 17 dollars pour l'emballage de
ce format donc c'est sûr que c'est pas
donné en même temps si je compare au
prix du fromage frais qu'on achèterait
en parallèle on est dans les mêmes eaux
je sais déjà ta réponse mais apprendre
ou à laisser je fais assez conquise
j'irai apprendre merci Isabelle pour les
découvertes analyses grand plaisir